E aí
[Música]
e o que você faria se você descobrisse
que só tem mais um dia de vida
e pensem sobre isso vocês tem algum
arrependimento o desejariam ter feito
alguma coisa diferente
Tá bom eu tenho certeza que todos aqui
responderam mentalmente que sim mas
normalmente as pessoas não dão a devida
importância para essa pergunta porque a
vem com uma hipótese
ninguém acha que a gente tem realmente
só mais um dia de vida mas será que é
assim mesmo que a gente deve pensar
sobre isso
nós estamos acostumados a deixar as
coisas para depois adiar compromissos ou
até mesmo diversões para o futuro e para
outro dia porque assim a gente sempre
acha que ele vai estar lá sempre achamos
que vamos ter a chance de fazer isso
depois Mas isso não é um fato e nenhuma
certeza e eu sinto que a pandemia veio
para nos ensinar isso para nos fazer
acordar e perceber tudo o que realmente
acontece à nossa volta e para nos fazer
parar de viver no modo automático
e no intervalo de duas semanas tudo
mudou o mundo inteiro foi obrigado a
parar e se Reinventar para lidar com um
vírus inédito que acabou levando a vida
de muitas pessoas inesperadamente
e nós somos impedidos por mais de um ano
de vida da forma que sempre soubemos
impedidos até mesmo de sair de casa para
ver a família Então tudo aquilo que você
tava deixando para depois de repente não
era mais possível se realizar
e eu acho que esse é o maior exemplo de
como a vida é curta e imprevisível e do
porque a gente não pode desperdiçar ela
sem seguir os nossos sonhos e as nossas
vontades e sem viver cada dia como se
fosse o último e eu sei que essa frase é
clichê mas ela não seria Clichê se não
fosse verdade Quantas coisas você tava
deixando para depois quando a pandemia
começou
a e agora mais quantas você continua
adiando para depois que a pandemia
acabar
isso tem que ter um fim nós temos
literalmente o poder de escolher a forma
como levamos a vida e muitas vezes por
causa de uma mentalidade fechada
acabamos criando motivos para afastar a
nossa própria felicidade
e existem cinco principais motivos do
Porque nós não somos felizes todos os
dias
é o primeiro motivo é insatisfação com o
que está acontecendo na sua vida e isso
acontece quando a gente ficar infeliz
Por que a vida ainda não está atingindo
as nossas expectativas Então você fica
apegado a essas expectativas e não se
permite ser feliz até que a vida te deu
o que quer então isso acontece quando a
gente tem um objetivo alguma meta que a
gente quer muito alcançar então a gente
mergulha de cabeça nisso trabalho o
tempo inteiro e muitas vezes até esquece
de fazer outras coisas por nós porque a
gente acha que depois que isso passar a
gente vai ter a chance de recuperar todo
esse tempo perdido o que depois que isso
passar aí sim a gente vai ser feliz
mas o problema com isso é que acaba se
tornando um ciclo e quando você atingir
essa meta você cria outra e depois outra
depois outra e assim você nunca é
realmente feliz de verdade
e o segundo motivo é o medo do futuro ou
do passado isso acontece quando a gente
sente medo preocupação por coisas que já
aconteceram e que não tem como mudar o
que coisas por coisas que não
aconteceram então vez em nunca aconteçam
Então você fica preso nesse ciclo de
reviver situações ruins ou imaginar
sentimentos ruins sem realmente viver o
que você tá vivendo agora e o que tá
acontecendo agora com você
é o terceiro motivo é escolhi esse
infeliz porque se beneficia de alguma
forma quando a gente leva essa frase a
gente acha um pouco estranho porque
ninguém imagina que sem feliz pode se
beneficiar Mas isso acontece por meio da
autopiedade muitas pessoas usam da
infelicidade como desculpa para receber
amor e solidariedade e para fugir e
desafios oportunidades de crescimento ou
qualquer coisa que te tire da sua zona
de conforto e assim subconscientemente
se impedir de falhar
é o quarto motivo são as expectativas
sociais isso acontece quando a gente
fica muito preocupado com o que o mundo
vai achar da gente a gente fica
preocupado em ser bem-sucedido em Não
Falha nunca e atinja as expectativas que
todos têm sobre nós mas o problema com
isso é que a gente acaba vivendo mais
pelos outros do que Pelas nossas
próprias voluntárias e as nossas
próprias expectativas
Oi e o último motivo eu acho que é o
mais comum no dia a dia de todos que é
dar muita importância às coisas erradas
e um exemplo que eu posso dar disso é
quando a gente disse que tá tendo um dia
ruim tudo que você teve mesmo um dia
ruim ou você teve uma coisa ruim que
aconteceu no seu dia bom e você deixou
com que ela tomasse conta de todo o
resto
e a gente tem o direito de escolher o
que que a gente quer dar mais
importância nos nossos dias EA claro que
a gente não tem sempre só Dias bons ou
dias ruins na verdade ensinava de novo
acontecer nada fora dessa rotina todos
os dias acabam só sendo dias mais ou
menos Dias normais mas por que que a
gente vai querer ter dias mais ou menos
a gente pode escolher trocar eles por
dias bons
Olá tudo só depende de uma mudança de
perspectiva
e o seu cérebro é programado para
procurar por evidências que confirmem
tudo aquilo que você disse então se a
história na sua cabeça é que ai eu não
tenho sorte com nada ou nada nunca dá
certo na minha vida o seu série vai
começar a procurar e ponto a tudo aquilo
nessa vida que só confirma o que você
disse ignorar tudo que te mostra o
contrário é por isso que é tão
importante a gente passar ver as coisas
por um outro lado e focar sempre nas
coisas que a gente já atende Positivo na
nossa vida ao invés de tudo aquilo que
ainda nos falta assim meu servo vai
começar a te escolher a escolher mostrar
essas coisas para você e você vai cada
vez mais conseguir ser feliz
e a sua realidade externa sempre vai
repetir a sua realidade interna como se
fosse um espelho Então vamos supor que
você se olha no espelho e você não gosta
do que você vê você nunca vai tentar
brigar contra o espelho certo não porque
você sabe que isso não vai sentido e
você sabe que o reflexo no espelho
sempre vai ajudar a mesma forma que você
e isso também vale para a vida então
quando a gente tem alguma situação
difícil alguma coisa que a gente tem que
enfrentar não adianta querer brigar
Contra isso porque dessa forma você só
vai estar refletindo a sua própria
perspectiva negativa da situação Ah mas
então o que a gente pode fazer para ir
em Direção a felicidade
eles têm três passos pelos quais a gente
pode começar e o primeiro deles é a
mudança de mindset de acordo com o livro
entitulado mãe da Carol do ECA existem
dois principais tipos de mentalidade a
mentalidade fixa EA mentalidade de
crescimento pessoas que têm a
mentalidade fixa São pessoas que têm uma
crença limitante São pessoas que
acreditam que o fracasso é uma medida
direta da sua competência e do seu valor
e que acham que tudo já tá meio
predestinado já as pessoas vão entrar de
crescimento São pessoas que estão sempre
buscando crescer melhorar que não se
deixam se definir pelo seu fracasso
muito pelo contrário que procuram
aprender como seus erros e que acreditam
que o seu esforço e o trabalho duro é o
que vão te levar ao sucesso na vida
a todos nós podemos ter um pouquinho da
mentalidade fixa e um pouquinho da
mentalidade de crescimento em áreas
diferenças nossa vida então o que a
gente tem que fazer é perceber em quais
áreas a gente tem uma mensalidade fixa e
se esforçar para mudar isso e passar ver
o fracasso por exemplo como não tentar
ao invés de tentar e errar
é a segunda mudança é viver no momento
presente e isso é simplesmente
aproveitar mesmo cada momento que a
gente vive sem se preocupar com outras
coisas externas então se você tá com a
sua família se você tá com seus amigos
realmente aproveitar esse momento com
eles ao invés de ficar se preocupando
com um trabalho que você tem que fazer e
ainda não entregou porque aquela
preocupação não pertence àquele momento
e aí para isso a gente precisa aprender
a definir Quais problemas são nossos
quais são do nosso eu do futuro e quais
são do nosso eu do passado então toda
vez que vocês se pegar se preocupando
com alguma coisa que não pertence ao seu
momento você decide que o seu eu do
futuro vai se preocupar com isso e
aproveita o que você tá vivendo agora
Oi e a terceira mudança eu acho que é a
mais simples e muitas vezes subestimada
que é praticar a gratidão e como eu
expliquei no começo o seu cérebro sempre
vai procurar aumentar tudo aquilo que
você mais da sua importância então se
todo dia você pensar em no mínimo três
coisas que te trazem gratidão você pode
literalmente mudar a sua vida inteira
porque isso vai te fazer focar em todas
as coisas que você já tem de bom na sua
vida e como tudo ainda pode melhorar e
assim você vai começar a cada vez mais
notar todas as coisas que te fazem feliz
e como você ainda tem muito para viver e
muito para ser feliz
a e é claro que a gente não vai ser
feliz sem por cento do tempo a gente
também precisa de momentos ruins ou até
mesmo Dias realmente ruins para que a
gente possa ter um equilíbrio e para que
a gente possa aprender com eles e
crescer com eles e esse processo não
acontece da noite para o dia cada um tem
o seu tempo e é exatamente sobre isso
que eu vim falar que hoje a gente não
precisa ser feliz só quando a gente
atingir aquela meta final que a gente
está buscando a gente pode também ser
feliz no caminho até lá e como a gente
viu pela pandemia a gente não tem
nenhuma certeza dia de amanhã e é por
isso que a gente precisa ser feliz hoje
fazer o que a gente ama hoje esse a
nossa melhor versão hoje obrigada a
[Música]